il a toujours dit et c'est pour ça que
non il dit la vérité il a toujours dit
que ça faisait fort il avait gagné près
d'auray 1,3 et bien sûr voilà maintenant
120 ans voilà rigole oui c'est énorme
c'est bien parce que sur mes freins les
gars c'était est est le numéro un des
pans numéro un ouais et à personne
d'autre une nuit mais au dessus de lui
il ya veille avaient la tête dans les
étoiles et c'est encore moi moi je
bossais sur secretstory à l'époque on
pouvait pas l'approcher benjamins n'ont
été tués mais c'est vrai il était tout
le temps avec un garde du corps on
pouvait pas l'approcher satena star
malade est toujours une non mais pas pas
énorme et non ils s'étaient pas un garde
du corps un certain gaston qui arrive
aux idées parce qu'il faut des bras
d'eau non non mais quoi c'est vrai quoi
mais en plus je la raconte pas brider
été nommé il était hyper cool à chaque
fois il y avait des filles soirée de fin
de tournage il est en tongues il était
déjà à l'époque benjamin je peux vous
dire quelque chose comme je suis un peu
d'accord avec eux moi je connaissais pas
mais à l'époque et c'est vrai que
j'avais un mauvais a priori surtout
alors que tu es tout mes frères n'ont
jusque là tuez vous on sait on a failli
se battre en boîte de nuit à très très
bon parce qu'il m'avait attaqué sur un
blouson qu'il aurait aimé avoir à
l'époque tu pouvais pas s'acheter qui
était un très beau 1920 c'est vrai il a
dit nous fait chier cas ce qu'a dit que
ces blousons de merde bien sûr et mon
pote jean phi lemonnier qui m'ont mis à
nus l'intensité croiseur en boîte et ils
avaient chauffé série d'offres il
pensait que c'était qu'à laisser faire
ils l'ont fait se taper dessus
en fait il n'a créé que le testing alors
que maintenant et je le dis je laime
survie mais les tuer tout le contraire
benjamins 2 est-ce que tu renvoyé à aux
téléspectatrices le jour et je vous
propose jouez vous remercier c'est que
effectivement l'émission de spa ou pas
ça a changé mon image dans ce sens là
c'est consommer pour à mes côtés je n'ai
jamais été pas du tout et et on en parle
c'est fait on après avec la chaîne tout
à l'heure c'est que j'ai fait une grosse
erreur et quand je suis allé sur celui
de la première fois pour faire nouvelle
star j'ai refusé de venir lundi sont mes
par connerie par lots j'ai perdu du
temps on s'est engueulés encore pendant
deux ans pour rien sur voilà les cours
ont fait rire mais je le dis aux
téléspectateurs et vous paraît sympa
mais même à l'époque un vrai qui sera
coté panneaux mais j'avais une image
terrible
après les pas été aidés il est sûr de
lui l'hélicoptère qui bosse et je veux
dire un truc sur toi benjamin benjamin
je vous le dis c'est juste un tifo et
benjamin continua de l'argent dans rôle
dit voilà il aime se faire plaisir à
tout le monde ça va décider du
générosité incroyable et benjamin en
fait il est comme ça mais justement il
la raccompagne tout c'est que c'est un
keeper il a envie voilà il semble a
beaucoup reproché un ouais ça partait en
vacances pas très loin j'ai emmené mes
copains par exemple des billets des noms
pour tout le monde est le témoin x tu
sais ce que je fais mais on part en
vacances très loin mais sur mes copains
chez moi mais bon c'est un problème
quand on est les amis qui ont moins
d'argent que soit comme les roses it est
exceptionnel s'effacera le côté plaie
d'argent n'est pas mortelle
exactement il ya 200 baron le tall à la
dent mais je suis très heureux en corée
balto lasserre